- I always like to finish up
with something that could
put a smile on your face.
This is What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
A Pacific Northwest artist
is spreading the message
that disabilities don't have
to hold you back from anything.
Even though he's blind,
he does incredible woodwork
just by sound and feel.
It's incredible!
And he's turned it into a full-time job.
He details it all in his TikTok
channel, The Blind Woodsman,
and people are fascinated,
as they should be.
He's got nearly 2 million followers.
We have him on the line right now,
watching on Fox 12, Oregon.
Everybody say hi to John!
- [All] What's up, John!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my!
(John laughs)
- I'm having a good day
up here in Washington.
How are you?
- Oh my God, I love Washington!
So wait, you've been a
woodworker for 15 years, right?
- That's right.
I was kind of having a
hard time finding my place
in the world and what I was gonna do
and I started attending a
woodshop at a Center for the Blind
in Salt Lake City, Utah,
and I found immediately that
I really had a knack for it.
I really understood it well,
and so, for the next couple of years,
I had actually become close friends
with the woodshop teacher,
and so I just kind of spent
the next few years honing
my woodworking skills
and that kind of a thing,
and now I am a professional artist
and I make functional art,
like bowls, cups, plates,
canisters, those kind of things.
- I mean,
(audience applauds)
your work is incredible, man!
I mean, congratulations on like, you know,
starting this and just killing it.
Like, it's incredible, your work.
So, tell us about your TikTok videos.
- Okay, so we like to make
videos about educating people
about blindness and disabilities
and things like that.
We wanna show 'em that
we're just regular people,
like anybody else.
We can do things if we put our mind to it.
And I also like to show my process,
like my adaptive measuring tool
and how I use that and
the way I use the tools.
I also have to say that I
definitely do not do this alone.
My wife, Anni, who is also
a very talented artist,
she does all the technical stuff.
I just make stuff and
look pretty. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
And we truly believe
that when you dispel ignorance,
fear and hatred go away.
- Oh, absolutely.
(audience cheering)
Well, you sent me one
of your latest projects.
I cannot wait.
This is so beautiful!
And the detail y'all.
(audience cheering)
I am so impressed by you.
Like, this is so incredible.
It must feel so good to be able
to make something like this.
Thank you so much for this
and John, you're just incredible.
You're such an inspiration.
We love you joining the show today.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(heart dings)
(audience clapping)
- [John] Thank you very much!
Thank you for the opportunity.
- Oh, absolutely.
Well, hey, that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot, pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and spreading positivity
just like you, my man.
So, they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Oh wow!
Thank you!
That's amazing!
I'll definitely be going
down to the wood store.
- Thank you so much, John
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Awkwafina, Charles Esten, Cindy, and Amy.
Y'all have a great day, and if it's not,
try and change it.